yeah i'm excited oh it's exciting all
right
because we just got our first look at
kristen stewart as princess diana in the
upcoming biopic
spencer and the resemblance is
wild thank you yep that's kristin
rocking a red blazer
a black hat with a short veil and
matching shirt
looking just like the princess of wales
with her signature
short blonde hair and guys get this
this outfit is almost identical to a
style diana wore in 1986
when she visited a spinal injuries unit
in england
i'm so proud diana who was born diana
spencer was married to prince charles
from 1981 to 1996.
they of course had two sons prince
william and prince harry
and in 1997 she died at the age of 36
after a car accident in paris france on
wednesday
neon the studio behind the film
announced that the movie is set to film
in both germany and the uk
before its fall 2021 release has begun
principal photography and while we don't
know a ton about the flick
we do know it's set in december 1991.
according to the synopsis here's what
it's about the prince and princess of
wales marriage has long since grown cold
though rumors of affairs and a divorce
abound
peace is ordained for the christmas
festivities at sandringham estate
there's eating and drinking shooting and
hunting diana knows the game
this year things will be a whole lot
different sounds
juicy right kristen also shared a bit
giving fans even
more insight explaining quote spencer is
a dive inside
an emotional imagining of who diana was
at a pivotal turning point in her life
it is a physical assertion of the sum of
her parts
which starts with her given name spencer
it is a harrowing effort for her to
return to herself
as diana strives to hold on to what the
name spencer means to her
well i don't know about you but i know
what i'm doing fall 2021.
there are so many perspectives of her
and of her story
that there's really hard it's hard to
determine like what is or isn't
it it's just not a black and white thing
and it's a really
it's just a very slippery really
emotionally
packed story for a lot of people it
caught up with a 30 year old actress
back in november and she opened up about
wanting to do diana's story justice
this is a really kind of like poetic
really internalized imagining
kind of like a really heavy like maybe
the heaviest like three days
time before she does something as gnarly
as
leaving the royal family and um yeah so
like i'd say
i'm just sort of like reading everything
that i can and then forgetting it
because it really it's kind of a really
like internal
internalized story